[Music]
alexandra is with us in hartford
connecticut hey alexander how are you
hey dave i'm good thank you how are you
better than i deserve how can we help
um so um i have kind of a decision that
i'm facing
so uh basically my husband and i have
made some poor choices over two years
in terms of like financial decisions um
and then pandemic hit and we both lost
our jobs
since then we've recovered and we kind
of had a very hard conversation
about like how to make us not um
so vulnerable again because we almost
lost our house and we have two kids
so i started on your program and i'm
using
every dollar app as of early october
last year uh and we were managed to kind
of get through
uh 17 342 dollars worth of debt
good so we have no more credit card debt
there is no card up
anymore medical bills are paid for
you're doing it you're doing it
yeah we've been very aggressive so we
haven't really been doing much like we
haven't done a vacation we haven't gone
out
or um we've gone out once but um
so how long did it take you to pay off
17 000
um so with the first payments we started
making mid-october
um since october so in four months you
did seventeen thousand dollars
yes we did yeah from both being
unemployed we're about to lose our house
where our baby's gonna sleep too now we
have no credit card debt no car debt no
medical debt
yes sir that's incredible what's your
household income
um so we went back back to work um my
husband went back to work at the end of
september
i went back to working at the end of
november yeah but what's your household
income a year
now right now it's 210 000
yay okay good all right
yeah so we are um we ended up kind of
like going through all of our accounts
and we found out that we were behind on
tax payments so we have some bad
back taxes which we are tackling this
month and it's going to be done
but i just have a little bit of trouble
planning for
kind of going forward um so we have
um both of the jobs offer
us 401k for retirement with a three
percent match
um but at the same time we also want to
kind of
continue being very aggressive in the
way that we tackled doubt
um and i um sort of and we also have
student loans
oh how much are your student loans
together it's 150 000 between me and my
husband
okay well you got a ways to go then you
just got to finish those up
yeah i just don't know like if we should
invest in our environment
and pay no no
you said you're going to follow the plan
crush everything you've been doing has
been following the plan
and then you almost fell off the wagon
just now and we grabbed your hand don't
fall off the wagon
remember you were smart and then the
pandemic hit and then you realized we're
not smart let's get a plan and then you
got a plan and now you're starting to
get too smart again
go back to the plan well it it just
feels like
if we don't uh because our our company
offers 401k it just feels like we're
we're going to be missing alexandria
it's time to get rid of your student
loans
okay they're going to be there the rest
of your freaking life if you keep
talking like this
okay so we should we should probably so
we should just opt out of the company
for one game yes you should opt out you
should stop that do you have any money
in savings
um we first got our like the first
savings badge we did
based on your plan which is thousand
dollars in cash we set it aside but this
is the first month that we've done it
okay and you do you have any other money
that is not in a retirement account
no okay all right so you make 200 000
a year and you have been averaging
about four thousand dollars a month
as you've gotten this jet off the ground
and now you're gonna start averaging
more than that because you need to be
putting a hundred thousand dollars a
year i want you to be done with this
these student loans in 18 months
okay that's five thousand dollars a
month
okay yeah that's still like super
aggressive and i feel like we're just
like
we're at home and we're we aren't doing
much um
and i kind of feel like i want to save
some money for retirement oh
my kids into activity um i'm 31.
okay in 18 months
you're not gonna ever have a student
loan again
or you're gonna keep arguing with me
what you've been doing for five minutes
about investing in your stupid 401k
you need to finish this you need to
finish this
you need to finish this 18 more months
is not going to mean
that you don't retire wealthy because
you didn't start your 401k to 33 instead
of
31. crap a year ago you weren't doing
anything in your 401k anyway
and you were broke and deeply in debt
remember
remember how dumb and how bad
don't do it again 18 months
you can do this and quit arguing with me
about your stupid 401k
if you want your kids to have activities
that's fine go be with them
well that's fine you can have like your
kids can have activities you make 200
000
a year i'm just putting 60 000 of that
that's all that's it five thousand
dollars a month
you can do this you can do it man but
dave it's hard i'm tired
do it do it do it do it don't argue with
the thing don't argue with what
millions of people have used at work
don't argue with it
quit fixing a plan that ain't broke